Rian has written a story that's unexpected but right.
Some of the stuff that happens, people are gonna be like, "Oh my god!"
Even though I think I know it all,...
...they throw things at me storywise I never could have imagined.
And even though everybody knows that it's the second in the trilogy,...
...it feels like its own thing.
Go!
Star Wars is so cool because there's all these creatures...
...and all these amazing visual effects.
But all the characters are also so complex.
Rian needs to work on his Wookiee sounds.
Ridiculous new director.
Can't even just learn a Wookiee sound.
It feels like the storylines are becoming established.
We're really getting to know these new characters,...
...also with the characters that we know and love.
We're seeing their lives change.
Everything is being shifted in the opposite way to what the audience expected after 7.
Rian has made Star Wars fresh and new.